bon on a défini les collectivités
territoriales on a essayé de démêler les
compétences entre les régions les
départements et des communes
et pourtant il reste un gros sac de
noeuds au niveau local qu'on n'a pas
encore vu la différence entre communes
et intercommunalités reprenons tout
d'abord rapidement les bases et parlons
un peu de la commune la commune est la
plus petites collectivités territoriales
françaises
on y élit un conseil municipal aux
élections municipales et c'est ce
conseil qui allait ensuite le maire en
termes de compétences la commune possède
une capacité d'intervention général pour
gérer toutes les affaires de la ville ou
du village sans que la loi soit obligé
de faire une liste stricte des limites
de ses compétences
c'est ce qu'on appelle la clause de
compétence générale
bien sûr malgré la clause de compétence
générale
la loi confie quand même certaines
tâches obligatoires à la commune en
france il y environ 35000 commune et 35
milles c'est beaucoup ces mêmes environ
40 pour cent de toutes les communes de
l'union européenne et du coup ça donne
parfois de toutes petites communes
bien sûr ça permet à la commune de
rester une collectivité territoriale de
proximité
mais le problème c'est que ce
morcellement du territoire par les
communes rend parfois difficile pour les
plus petites communes d'assumer les
dépenses de certains besoins importants
pour les habitants comme la gestion des
déchets ou le ramassage scolaire par
exemple et c'est pour ça que certaines
villes ou villages joignent leurs forces
pour réaliser ensemble des projets
communs
on appelle ces unions des établissements
publics de coopération intercommunale ou
opci
c'est le nom compliqué pour parler des
intercommunalités
pour créer une intercommunalité c'est
assez simple il faut un vote des
conseils municipaux des communes
concernées et un arrêté préfectoral qui
valide la création il est important de
souligner que même si l'intercommunalité
est une réunion de plusieurs communes ce
n'est pas d'une collectivité
territoriale
seule la commune en est une il ne faut
pas confondre les intercommunalités et
les communes nouvelles
les communes nouvelles ne sont pas des
coopérations intercommunales
mais des communes qui ont fusionné pour
donner une nouvelle commune et du point
de vue du fonctionnement de
l'intercommunalité
c'est une organisation qui copie
globalement celle d'une commune à la
place du conseil municipal
il y à un comité syndical ou un conseil
communautaire à la place des conseillers
municipaux
il y à des délégués communautaires les
délégués communautaires sont élus au
suffrage universel direct en même temps
que les conseillers municipaux et enfin
le chef de l'intercommunalité n'est pas
un maire mais un président concernant
les compétences des intercommunalités
certaines sont obligatoires en fonction
de la taille de l'intercommunalité
mais sinon c'est des communes de
l'intercommunalité qui décide quelles
compétences elle délègue
d'ailleurs je vous conseille d'aller
voir votre mairie pour démêler qui fait
quoi entre votre commune et votre
intercommunalités car il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui la loi oblige toutes les
communes à faire partie d'une
intercommunalité
bon du coup vous savez à quoi servait
intercommunalités comment elles se
forment et comment elle fonctionne et si
et la vie était simple on pourrait
terminer des explications ici oui mais
la vie n'est pas simple
des petits bouts l'intercommunalité il y
en a plein et on va tout les passer en
revue mais pas tout de suite on vous
garde ça pour une prochaine vidéo en
tout cas merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout laissez nous un
commentaire et un pouce en l'air on se
retrouve bientôt pour de nouvelles
vidéos
à bientôt